everyone loves a good ghost story
whether you're crowded around a campfire
or watching a youtube video at 3am
there's something fun and exciting about
imagining haunted places plagued by
strange noises and apparitions
part of what makes it so fun is the idea
that any place can be haunted
especially if terrible things have
happened there that decrepit old house
at the end of your street
that 80 year old movie theater where no
one goes anymore
a park where one too many kids went
missing
all it takes is a tragic backstory and a
creepy atmosphere
and it's easy to believe that any place
could be teeming with restless spirits
so it stands to reason that a place with
as many
unsolved deaths as the scp foundation
might have a ghost or two
lurking in the shadows if you've ever
suspected that the scp foundation might
be
haunted well you'd be right it began
as all good ghost stories do with a
series of frightening
unexplained events some time ago
personnel at scp foundation site 30
began to notice strange things happening
around the facility
obviously at a place like an scp
foundation containment site
strange is relative but these events
seem to have nothing to do with any of
the entities contained at the site
there were unexplained sounds reported
in the private quarters of agents and
researchers
ranging from whispers to screams from an
unseen
being personnel who approached the
d-class block at the site noticed an
immediate drop in temperature
with some employees claiming that they
could even see their own breath
several personnel reported items going
missing while they were alone in a room
most were small and easily misplaced
objects like pens and clipboards
but one man said his wallet disappeared
which wouldn't be that strange if it
hadn't been securely
inside his lab coat other personnel
would be innocently washing their hands
only to be horrified by the appearance
of a bloody figure in a d-class jumpsuit
in the mirror
staring back at them with hatred in its
eyes
there were anomalous computer server
errors the feeling of being watched or
followed by some menacing invisible
force
even the side of a shadowy silhouette
fleeing down
corridors and hiding around corners all
of these occurrences were reported to
higher-ups at the foundation
but they were all dismissed the
directorial board of the site insisted
that these accounts were likely the
result of employees cracking under the
immense mental stress of working under
such strenuous circumstances
if left alone they were certain that the
reports would stop
but the reports didn't stop and they
soon found out that this was
only the beginning there was an uptick
in containment breaches following these
initial reports
in total 12 different entities were
released from their containment and the
origin of these breaches could not be
identified
thankfully the entities were captured
and returned to their containment
facilities before any casualties could
result
but from there things kept getting worse
over the course of several months there
were six different employee suicides on
site
security footage of the deceased
operatives shortly before their deaths
showed them acting deeply troubled
engaging an agitated conversation with
someone not visible to the camera
at first it was posited that whoever was
upsetting the employees was in a blind
spot
but it quickly became clear that the
dead employees were being tormented by
something invisible
stories of hauntings were one thing but
now with escaped scps and a notable
death count
the directorial board decided to mount
an official investigation into the
unexplained occurrences
it was then that the spirit was
officially acknowledged
identified and reclassified as scp-49
scp-4973 was once a d-class worker
who was used as a guinea pig in 25
different experiments with a variety of
entities on site
he was reportedly exposed to multiple
unusual and dangerous anomalies
including scp-158 a large mechanical arm
capable of extracting an
unidentified substance from any living
test subject
before he was brought on board at scp
foundation site 30
he was also known as gordon carvilus
markovic
a man who had been convicted of murder
in the second degree after stabbing his
wife
24 times in the chest with a kitchen
knife
during his incarceration markovic was
transferred to the custody of the scp
foundation and placed at site-30
where he was given a new name d-10000
during an experiment involving a
redacted entity
d-10000 was killed and his remains were
disposed of at a nearby waste refinery
it was then only three months after his
death that the initial reports of ghost
activity began
scp-4973 is regarded as a class
iv spectral entity meaning that it is an
entity displaying a high degree of
aggression
and malevolence towards a specific
individual or group
in this case the spirit displays
hostility towards a very specific group
the scp foundation class 4 entities can
affect the environment around them
move objects reduce the temperature in a
room and induce hallucinations in humans
that it comes into contact with
these hallucinations are thought to be
the cause of the increase in employee
suicides that occurred after 4973s first
appearance
one of the many ways in which scp-4973
acted out
in what is believed to be an attempt at
revenge on the foundation as a whole
was to somehow gain access to the
skipnet database terminal
this allowed the spirit to learn about
the entities contained at the site
as well as personal details regarding
the lives of research
security and administrative staff
working there
this information is likely what allowed
4973 to cause several suspected
containment breaches
though the specifics of those breaches
have been expunged from
official records 4973 was eventually
contained within an apparatus known as
the incorporeal entity
vacuum chamber which is constantly
monitored by a team of specialists
within
mtf mew13 affectionately nicknamed
ghostbusters in order to prevent it from
escaping
four harrington hollow neutralizer wards
have been placed at the door to the
containment facility
this containment method has been largely
effective though the spirit had escaped
a handful of times and had to be
recaptured and placed back into the ievc
in order to understand as cp 4973
and how it was able to access the
database dr lorraine casper
was assigned to conduct an interview
with the spirit speaking to it as it was
in containment
and a transcript of this interview was
available in the official foundation
archives
dr casper began the conversation
politely
addressing the scp as gordon and asking
him how he was
gordon refused to comply with the round
of questioning
going as far as to yell at dr kasper
until she reminded him that he faced the
risk of termination if he refused to
answer
her questions dr kasper pointed out that
the files accessed by 4973 required
clearance that the spirit would have no
way of possessing
he responded that he simply waved his
hand across the terminal in order to
access it
explaining it freaked out for a second
and just
stopped i could just move my fingers
around the air and the tabs would just
roll up
easy as that dr casper asked for
clarification
inquiring how he could even do something
like that 4973 continued his explanation
beats me it felt like some attraction
like magnets from a fog and
closer and closer i don't know something
like that finding this answer
unsatisfactory
dr casper pushed further asking for an
explanation of scp-4973's attempts to
release dangerous on-site anomalies from
containment
this question seemed to stump him and he
claimed not to understand what dr casper
meant
she explained that the id cards of dr
yurkov and dr orson were used to open
the facilities from which these
anomalies escaped
4973 was shocked that he had even been
suspected of this attack
and insisted not to know who orson or
yurkov
even were all of a sudden he trailed off
there was silence for a moment and dr
casper began to collect her notes and
leave assuming that the interview was
over
much to her surprise as cp 4973 began to
laugh
a loud uproarious laugh of complete and
utter delight casper asked what 4973 was
laughing about
and was met with the response god this
whole time you and your ghost hunting
crew never knew
he refused to clarify what it was the
doctor and her crew had missed
only saying god that look on your face
when you find out it's been right on
your nose this whole time
he continued to laugh at dr casper for
the remainder of the interview
refusing to answer any further questions
or explain
any of his comments finally dr casper
grew exasperated and left
ending the interview for real this time
following this perplexing interview
dr kasper inexplicably abandoned her
post at site 30.
her supervisors could not reach her
neither could any of the other
researchers at the site
no one had heard from her for an entire
week until one day she called director
eric riverson of site 30 on his personal
phone line
he recorded the conversation that a
transcript has been included in the file
for scp-4973
dr casper explained to director riverson
that she had been hiding in her private
residence away from the site
and that she no longer considered any
part of the site safe
in fact she suggested that all scp
foundation sites might be potentially
compromised
she explained her conversation with
scp-4973
and the questions it provoked her to ask
if he had not been behind the
containment breaches
then who was he never encountered dr
yurkov
or orson in any of the tests
administered on him and orson wasn't
even employed at the foundation until
after 4973's death dr kasper posited
that
though the spirit of gordon was not
responsible for the breaches
another spectral force or forces at the
site
might be her hypothesis that site 30 was
positively infested with the vengeful
spirits of class-d
employees lost over the years during
various experiments
in order to prove her theory dr casper
got her hands on all the experimental
equipment used by the department
researching spectral anomalies
the general consensus among researchers
in this field is that spirits leak out a
kind of energy
known as ectoplasm wherever they go it
has been compared to the skin left
behind when a spider or a snake
molts a non-essential portion of the
entity that is shed and leaves a residue
in areas where they have been
unsurprisingly a huge amount of
ectoplasm was detected
inside of site 30. the spirits were
undetected at first
as many of them were dormant for quite
some time dormant spirits are spirits
that are not aware of their surroundings
or the circumstances of their deaths
and they do not emit large quantities of
ectoplasm
it is likely that after gordon was
trapped several of the dormant spirits
of side 30 began to remember
what was done to them and manifest in
more aggressive ways
because gordon was presumed to be the
only spirit at the site
their gradual appearance in acting out
was either ignored or presumed to be
gordon escaping from containment
after her realization dr casper
identified an additional five active
spirits at the site
and was able to capture and contain one
of them dr casper warned director
riverson that they were likely far more
spirits than just those
five and it was only a matter of time
before they woke up and became active
like the others
the large amount of previous containment
breaches attributed to simple human
error
becomes deeply sinister once it is clear
that there have been vengeful spirits
hiding in plain
sight the entire time as gordon put it
in his interview
they were just under their noses the
whole time
dr kasper's findings and the story of
site 30 present a troubling possibility
every scp foundation site has used
massive amounts of class d
personnel and human experiments with
dangerous entities
and the body count at nearly all of them
is staggering
if dr kasper is right then every single
site has the makings of a haunted house
all of them could be infested with the
spirits of dead angry d-class
who are just waiting to wake up and take
their revenge on the still-living
members of the organization that killed
them
and it's only a matter of time before
they get the chance now check out
scp-3999
i am at the center of everything that
happens to me and scp-1007
mr life and mr death for more
mind-blowing
scp stories